Keating or eating so nennen die das in
Großbritannien essen oder heizen das ist
die Frage viele Haushalte fast 20%
müssen Sie sich jetzt stellen denn Sie
können es sich nicht mehr leisten beides
zu machen eine Energierechnung eine
Gasrechnung ist für den
Durchschnittshaushalt da jetzt 2500
Pfund das sind fast 3000 €, die food
banks die sogenannten das ist das was
bei uns die Tafeln sind sagen noch nie
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sind so viele
Leute in der Schlange man kommt nicht
mehr hinterher England wird zum kranken
Mann Europas und die können die
Rückschritte die sie durch den brexit
erlebt haben jetzt nicht mehr einholen
und ich glaube auch Deutschland läuft
Gefahr in diese Richtung zu gehen wenn
wir nicht ganz schnell wach werden das
ist hier in der Runde schon angeklungen
und wenn wir nicht das was uns immer
gedient hat und was ich bewährt hat in
unserem Land nämlich die Industrie
festhalten und weiter fördern
heizen oder Essen das klingt
unvorstellbar brutal das ist Menschen
gibt die von dieser Entscheidung stehen
im du hast es gerade schon so ein
bisschen angedeutet lass uns einmal
tiefer reingehen glaubst du da ist
Großbritannien durch den brexit und
durch viele andere Sachen ein Sonderfall
beschreib uns einmal genauer warum du
glaubst dass dieses Szenario auch
Deutschland zumindest drohen könnte also
um deine erste Frage zu beantworten es
ist ein Sonderfall weil England ja ein
extrem tertiären Sektor hat heißt
Dienstleistung ne Versicherung Anwälte
Rückversicherung genau
das heißt sie sind ihre abhängig vom
globalen Markt und wenn in der Welt
Sachen passieren die Instabilität
bedeuten dann wackelt England die immer
mit was sie nicht mehr haben ist
Textilindustrie Schwerindustrie
Eisenindustrie Stahlindustrie alles was
hier in Deutschland zum Teil zumindest
noch da ist Bergbau gibt es auch nicht
mehr in England die Sachen also die man
anfassen kann Autos das gibt's ja nicht
mehr es ist nicht mehr griffig und wir
in Deutschland haben ein größeren Anteil
als die Briten an diesen Industrien an
der Industrie und ich glaube dass das
der Unterschied ist der uns im Moment
wie so ein Puffer noch schützt aber das
ist eben vergänglich ich glaube das
trifft bei Ihnen auch einen wunden Punkt
sprochen die gleichen Fehler ja kann
sein also ich habe viel mit dem Briten
gearbeitet und kenne mich dann ein
bisschen aus war da in solchen
Diskussionsrunden nur mit dabei auf der
Insel und natürlich haben die nach
Lehman Brothers vor 12 Jahren begriffen
dass sie wieder ein bisschen retouring
machen müssen wieder ein bisschen
Industrie Wertschöpfungsketten wieder
schließen auf der Insel begriffen haben
sie die Umsetzung war kompliziert das
zeigt mir eins wenn du es mal verloren
hast ist es weg du kriegst das nicht so
schnell wieder auf die Beine gestellt
das verflochtene System von Handwerk von
freiberufen und von produzierten Gewerbe
das ist ein Meisterwerk und das ist nur
Werk da kannst du nicht ein Rädchen
rausnehmen er spielt keine Rolle mach
mal was anderes nee da läuft das Ding
nicht mehr und das ist glaube ich der
entscheidende Punkt also die auch bei
den Franzosen mit ihrer Staatswirtschaft
man kann in den anderen Ländern gucken
was passiert wenn du nicht eben so einen
starken Mittelstand hast ja im Dreieck
mit dem Handwerk und im Freien Berufen
eine stabile Einheit bildet und die in
der Lage sind mehr zu exportieren als
Großbritannien und Frankreich zusammen
nach der Krise wieder nein also Betrieb
jetzt zu machen die nicht Insolvenz
gehen auch so zu machen verlagern ihren
Standort die machen eine Beerdigung
zweiter Klasse na ja wir machen jetzt
erstmal zu ne wie ist der Minister
vorgeschlagen hat in seiner Weisheit und
das heißt dann im Prinzip weil was weiß
ich Aluminiumproduktion die wird dann
eben in Deutschland nicht mehr geben
wenn du auf dem Weltmarkt zweieinhalb
bis 3000 € pro Tonne bezahlst und du
produziert für 7 bis 8000 € wegen einer
Energiekosten was das eben du kannst
nicht wirtschaftliche Wirtschaft nicht
weiterführen das wissen wir als alte der
Bürger ganz genau das ist nicht klappt
es ihnen zu viel Schwarzmalerei na ja
also ich glaube es ist schon auch in
Deutschland so ich habe jetzt die letzte
Umfrage nicht ganz genau im Kopf aber
das bis zu 50% der Leute sagen sie geben
praktisch ihr ganzes verfügbares
Einkommen im Moment aus für die laufen
also für Essen und und heißen und und
was eben sonst noch so anfällt das ist
ja auch schon ganz schön hart und ich
glaube diese ganze Hand in den Mund
alles ja und dass ich glaube das
verunsichert Menschen auch sehr also
gerade die deutschen neige im Prinzip
schon auch so Vorsicht und sparen
eigentlich auch in Spanien ganz gerne
und ob man das fand man immer nicht so
klug weil man sagt aber es ist jetzt
eben ganz schwierig also auch nur das
beruhigende das beruhigende sparen zu
machen und das führt natürlich nicht zu
einer zu einer wahnsinnig guten Stimmung
und deswegen ist die Frage schon was
kann man gegen die Inflation machen die
ja die Preise so wahnsinnig treibt und
das ist eben das Teufels die Regierung
macht jetzt ein milliardenschweres
Hilfsprogramm nach dem anderen sie
kriegt dafür wenig Zuneigung vom Bürger
weil man nämlich im Einzelnen gar nicht
durchschaut was kommt mir davon jetzt
eigentlich kommt mir davon eigentlich
irgendwas zu Gute was hilft das
eigentlich ähm aber diese aber diese
riesige ständig steigende
staatsverschuldigung ich habe sehr große
Bundeshaushalt
also die die treibt natürlich auch die
Inflation die wahnsinnig irgendwann
müssen die Gewerkschaften nachziehen und
sagen wir brauchen halt entsprechende
Lohnabschlüsse und ich meine jetzt was
hatten oder was also 8%, das ist ja
schon sehr viel also wir haben den
letzten Jahren nie gehabt aber es ist
immer noch weg sofort an der
Supermarktkasse und das ist natürlich
das ist natürlich wahnsinnig schlimm
er hat gesagt das wird ein Winter der
Armut werden nicht hier Deutschland Herr
fast bei der kommen wir durch diese
Krise ist es Schwarzmalerei was glauben
sie ist das nicht ich glaube das große
Problem ist dass unsere Politik und auch
unsere Diskussion sich eigentlich immer
darum drehen wie können wir den Status
Quo in irgendeiner Form halten
gewährleisten ja also ich will keine
Werbung aber ich habe ja vor zwei Wochen
ein Buch veröffentlicht das heißt das
unheimliche jahrhundert und das dreht
sich genau darum dass wir in eine Epoche
hineinlaufen in der vor allem erst
einmal der Status Quo nicht zu halten
sein wird historisch machen
und sagen wir müssen den Gürtel enger
schneiden vergessen sie mal 23
Stichwort Großbritannien ist interessant
Großbritannien war das erste
Industrieland Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts
Großbritannien hat ein Vorlauf von
ungefähr 100 Jahren ja vor uns und
Industrie ja sind wir haben historische
Lebenszyklen ähm Metall etc das was in
Großbritannien jetzt geschieht muss uns
dazu veranlassen daraus zu lernen
was ganz wichtiges angeht Handwerk
Mittelstand ja die wir werden die
Kfz-Industrie in dem Ausmaß nicht halten
können weil die künftigen Autos wenn es
elektroautos werden die werden billiger
und mit viel weniger Teilen mit viel
weniger Menschen also ganz anderen wenn
dieser ganze Zeit wegbringen wir werden
uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen dass
die Kfz-Industrie die Chemieindustrie
die Metallindustrie zumindest stark
dezimiert wird unser großes Pfund ist
der Mittelstand und wenn wir den
Mittelstand jetzt steuerlich nicht
stützen aber den Mittelstand nicht durch
massive Bildung und das dass wir auch
das Handwerk wieder zum Glück gibt's ja
jetzt Initiativen wo man sagt Leute geht
nicht alle auf die Uni lernten Handwerk
ja man kann als Handwerk inzwischen hat
man wesentlich bessere Lebensaussichten
also Einkommensaussichten als in vielen
akademischen Fächern ja darauf das ist
die Chance und das meine ich mit von
England lernen nicht fest überlegen
jetzt wie können wir vermeiden dass
unsere alten Industrien sterben das
können wir nicht vermeiden ja aber wie
wo wir jetzt sehen England wie können
wir besser darauf reagieren und wir
haben glaube ich rückläufige Start
Zahlen in den vergangenen Jahren da muss
man sich dann auch noch mal fragen also
wie schwer machen wir das Menschen ist
es auch schwer ne das das kommt
natürlich dazu also klar das ist der das
ist der corona-effekt aber es war glaube
ich auch vorher schon so und es ist
einfach die Frage wie viel Bürokratie
erfordert sozusagen die Umsetzung einer
einer neuen Idee Zurückhaltung könnte es
auch beim Start gehen wenn man so seit
2010 oder 12 40 % Zuwachs bei den
Bundesbehörden und bei der
Bundesregierung das sind schon nicht
also da würde ich sagen ein bisschen
Zurückhaltung auch nicht verkehrt und
mir fehlt eben auch die
Bildungsoffensive das eine ist gerne ins
Handwerk gehen das andere ist studiert
aber studiert doch nicht alle
Politikwissenschaft also so
ist die Bildungsoffensive zum Beispiel
genau für den Energiebereich da ist so
viel so viele Fragen übrigens ja